at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up from
you
if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's l helix x
sleep dot com slash tim for up to two
hundred dollars off
so check it out one more time helix h e
l i x sleep dot com slash time
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free electrolyte drink
mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto
low carb or paleo diet or if you drink a
ton of water and you might
not have the right balance that's often
when i drink it or if you're doing any
type of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist
and two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units fbi
sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it
element will give you your money back no
questions ask they have extremely low
return rates so again element lmnt came
up with a
very special offer for you guys they've
created tim's club
just go to drinkelement.com
tim select subscribe and save and use
promo code tim's club
to get the 30 count box of element for
only 36 dollars
this will be valid for the lifetime of
the subscription and you can pause at
any time
so again check it out it's drink
lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club one more time
drink lmnt element so drink
lmnt.com tim and promo code tim's club
check it out
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
and my guest today i'll keep this intro
short is kelly slater
many people will know that name kelly is
widely considered the greatest
surfer of all time he holds nearly every
major record in the sport including 11
world titles and 55 career victories
he also has the amazing distinction of
being both
the youngest and oldest world champion
in men's history
his most dominant days were in the mid
90s when he won five straight titles
between 1993
and 1998 after topping mark richard's
previous record of four
straight titles kelly tried his hand at
retirement in 1999
he failed he then rejoined the tour
full-time in 2002.
suppose he sensed that he had many many
good years left and over the following
five years faced his toughest rival in
hawaii's andy irons
who got the better of him for three
straight years their heated battles
became the most compelling in the sports
history
propelling it to new heights kelly
finally reclaimed the title in 2005 and
repeated in 2006
and of course went on to gather many
more
titles slater that is kelly slater of
course will also be remembered
for the amazing wave pull technology
that he and his team of engineers at
kelly slater waveco
brought to life in 2015. the technology
has the potential to
reshape the surfing landscape for
generations and
you have to see video to really quite
grasp and grok
what that means but i encourage you to
do so you can find
him online at kellyslater.com and on
instagram and facebook
at kelly slater and without further ado
please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with
kelly slater
kelly welcome to the show hey thanks tim
i appreciate you making the time
and speaking of time i i want to just
sort of set the table for people
so you and i are on opposite sides of
the planet in a sense and
i wanted to start with something that
came up when we were texting because
i know in scheduling this i am in texas
you're currently in australia and so the
choice
was do we do crack of dawn your time or
really late at night and we ended up
doing
late at night so it's late your time and
you texted about taking
a two-hour bath i actually do take a lot
of baths just
because um it's kind of an easy way to
just let your body detox
in hot water and i did you know for
about the last two months i haven't been
working out or
really even surfing very much so uh this
past week i started working out again
and kind of built up a lot of the lactic
acid in the muscles i was working out
with a
with a friend of mine who's like a
brother tom carroll who was
two-time world champ back in the early
80s fellow surfer lives right up the
street here from where i'm staying and
and uh we spent a lot of time together
over the years surfing and training
together but
uh did a workout the other day and uh
i've been surfing the last
couple days yesterday surf pretty hard
the day before that i i surfed a bunch
and uh so you know those muscles are
just getting kind of worked again
that i don't usually uh sit and and uh
let the lethargic side of me build up
too much especially this time of year
i'm surfing almost every day usually
let's talk about we we touched on the
baths for a second and we can't believe
everything we read on the internet but
i did see if we're looking at morning
routines i did see
that in an interview with huckberry it
seems that you start a lot of your
mornings with a glass of warm water with
lemon
is that true or is that not true it is
yeah just just to uh
just get a little warmth going in the
body loosen up yeah get
uh obviously um
lemon's really good for you it's
alkalizing even though it's an acid it's
alkalizing in the body and it's got a
lot of
minerals and some vitamins and and um
just a nice clean way to kind of wake
your system up and
to me it feels better than putting
something heavy in my body
do you drink coffee i do a little bit
but i'm i'm 100
not like a coffee addict i don't know
really what good coffee is i kind of
like the smell of coffee more than i
like the taste of it
mm-hmm has that always been the case
with coffee or
was there an eye drag no i've never been
a coffee drinker i
intentionally have really kind of stayed
away from coffee i i feel like i drink
it a little bit now
just to be ready for it but uh this one
time i went to
this is the reason i really don't drink
coffee i went to france
and um we spend sort of the two months
prior to going to france to compete
on west coast time and tahitian time and
um
those are the events prior to going over
to europe we get to europe and we
compete within like a day or two of
getting there
and it's nine hour time difference going
east and that's the hardest thing when
you fly east you just
i don't care if it's from west coast to
east coast just even three hours is
tough to get
back on track but when i fly over to
europe it's really hard for me it takes
me almost a month to feel like i get
into like a morning routine and uh
i was going for a world title in the
early 2000s over there
and i drank a coffee one morning to wake
up and i got the jitter so bad
i fell off on every wave i was i caught
in this heat it was a really crucial
heat for me
to try and win and uh if i won that heat
it was pretty much a shoe-in for the
world title that year and
i did everything possible to lose that
heat and somehow want it but it was good
i drank a big coffee in the morning
didn't have any food
so it really kind of scared me away from
coffee
now this might be and please correct me
if i'm wrong but i had asked you
for and i appreciate you contributing to
my last book
tribe of mentors and the question was
how is a failure or a parent failure set
you up for later success do you have a
favorite failure of yours and you
mentioned i narrowly lost a world title
and surfing in 2003
after basically having locked it up the
month prior and then you went on to talk
about how it felt terrible but drove you
to clear up a lot of things
was that the same competition or a
different competition
that was a different competition could
you speak to that that loss in 2003
since we're on it just how that came to
be
and what it drove you to do afterwards
you had to bring that up huh tim i did
you know
i just dehumanized the the immortal
superhuman kelly slater you know
i'm kidding actually i do look back at
that
as i mean obviously there's no world
title it is sitting in your hands it
slips through that you're not
upset about on some level but if i could
go back and change anything i really
don't think i would because
it was a real very clear
indication of where things were going
wrong for me
and also to sort of charge the battery
back up
make me dig deeper and competitively
speaking
and uh skill set speaking with my
surfing and motivation all these things
it was just kind of a reset for me it
was rebooting the software in my brain
in a lot of ways and
those are tough lessons i lost that
world title to andy irons
and i was in a relationship that was
just wrong um
i literally didn't sleep the night
before that competition in a fight with
my
then girlfriend literally the whole
night she was fighting with my mom
it was just a nightmare so that's
terrible
oh it's terrible it was terrible i woke
up the next i didn't even wake up the
next morning i didn't sleep
maybe i got 30 minutes 40 minutes to
sleep that night i walked out of my
house the next morning walked behind the
house
and i saw two friends of mine and uh i
believe my little brother was there too
and
i just just started bawling i just broke
down like
everything felt wrong and i was you know
i knew in my heart i was going to lose
the world title that day
and if if you're in the right frame of
mind i think as a competitor
if you lose it hurts but you know it's
not life it's just a loss
but that was deeper because i had all
these other things that it was it was
such a clear
indicator that i was off in a lot of
different areas and
i had some work to do and those things
are painful sometimes and
you know it was one of those days did
you find that that loss
took you a while to climb out of
or was it waking up the morning after
and immediately
deciding on changes that you were going
to make could you just
perhaps describe what the days or weeks
were like following that it definitely
wasn't
the next day it was i would say it was
the next year
maybe about a it took me about a year
to um sort of you know get my act
together and um
straighten a lot of things out i
remember going into the next year my my
father died no two
and then um i'm pretty sure it was his
birthday
the following year that i lost the world
title actually on his birthday
i was still a little bit down in the
dumps about that and the loss hurt so
bad that i kind of just went into my
shelf for most of the next year
competitively speaking
and at the start of 2005
i remember we went to our opening it's
sort of the end of the year beginning of
the year banquet
and where they they crown the world
title officially but they also start the
year
and i remember walking out of there and
um at that point andy irons had won two
thousand two
three and four and i remember walking
out
as we were leaving and i saw joel
parkinson who was you know also
a world title contender and i just said
to him
i said who's it going to be this year me
or you one of us got to take this guy
out
and i remember in that moment just
feeling like i'm ready
you know i'm not scared to lose and i
really felt like
i could beat joel and would be joel and
i felt very confident that
you know with no fear and just going out
and
feeling it that i could that i would
beat andy so that year was a
huge turnaround and andy and i had a lot
of head-to-heads
and the rivalry really peaked that year
you know like he won a conus in japan
and then i won a contest in uh south
africa
and then he won a contest and i want to
kind of we're going back and forth and
i was thriving in it i just it was
exciting me
you know i just thought in my head you
know i've already lost this guy
before it's not going to hurt any worse
this time so i might as well put
everything into it i can and i just took
a totally different headspace than 2004
when i just kind of
shied away from the whole thing and then
it just all it all just fell in my lap
really it all
it all just everything just kind of
lined right up and it was almost
unbelievable because
it felt like the matrix kind of thing
where you just see it playing out
even if you make a mistake it plays out
in your favor somehow and
that whole year that whole year went
that way for me
what did your self-talk or prep
look like that particular year when
you're seeing the matrix unfolding
say in some of the more important
competitions how did it differ from
years before if at all i don't think it
differed
necessarily i think it got back into the
groove you know i think i felt out of
that
confident place and out of that you know
when you're getting the flow and you get
in the zone
you don't question it and if you start
to question it you kind of
um you know you start to fall out of it
but then you get to a place where you're
really
you know i feel like if you're really
mastering that feeling and that that
place for yourself that you can kind of
step back and watch it also
and even get stronger you you kind of
embolden yourself into that
so i i felt like my surfing was there my
competing was there i felt unstoppable
and i just built on that confidence and
i never questioned it
you know i knew it wasn't going to be
easy to be andy because you know i
really did have this
light and dark good and evil kind of
love hate
all that kind of a rivalry between us
and
you know we're very different kinds of
people but we also
identified with each other a lot and he
grew up watching me and saying i was
kind of like his inspiration
and then when he became my rival he said
he
hated me and wanted me to die you know
so it was like
it felt real personal like he just he
had made no bones about it he was like
the first person i ever competed with
that
i felt was really on that level and just
said i'm you know he
he just goes i want to just smash all
his dreams and he would say in
interviews and stuff and
it's intense you got to step up to that
or or
you know step away yeah it was the first
time i ever felt someone
that way in my face before and uh in the
end it was
it was really good for me but it was it
was tough at times
if we look at 2003 if you're willing to
go into it one of the
things that popped out because i think
that the wins and we're going to talk
about obviously a lot of
the successes people are aware of a lot
of the successes but how
you have maintained
and honed your skills with such
longevity i think is
one of the more impressive things and so
i like to talk about the bumps along the
way
and in 2003 coming back to that you
mentioned your dad died
in o2 i was reading an outside magazine
interview
and i'll just read this and then i'd
love to hear you speak
to what it means but losing his father
paved the way for what slater described
as an expanded awareness then while
taking early season break in 2003
between events in australia his adopted
second home
a close friend challenged him to lead
his family's emotional recovery
not be victimized by it the words were
penetrating in slater
with his friend's encouragement enrolled
in a series of local therapeutic
workshops that helped him identify
troublesome behavior patterns and
emotional sand traps
now there's a little bit of context we
need to fill in here but could you speak
to i guess
a bit of your childhood for those who
don't have any context
and then what happened in 2003 if what i
read
is any way to lead into it you know my
childhood
i think as for most kids it feels normal
you know like what you know seems like
the normal thing but looking back now
my my dad was drinking a lot my mom it
really made her crazy
and um you know when you have alcoholism
or gambling or whatever you have in your
fam if you have you know some kind of
big issue like that in your family
everyone else kind of falls in line you
know like some people are enablers
some people are mediators some people
are you know become aggressive some
become you know
you react to it different ways and um
and
it kind of creates this sort of maze and
puzzle that all sort of
makes sense in that in that environment
but there's a lot of
unhealthy survival skills and that kind
of thing
right you know but there were other
families that were worse off than mine
that were friends of mine you know
so it didn't seem that outlandish or
anything but my mom probably harbored us
from a lot of the stuff
and we didn't know maybe you know some
of the things that were happening
like kids shouldn't but you know a lot
of my feelings are a lot of my
memories are pretty good you know i i
don't feel like i grew up in
like any kind of a physical abuse
situation like some people have or
whatever but getting on with it i also
didn't learn a lot of skills that
helped me evolve and mature emotionally
at a young age so i was at times really
shy when i was
younger in my teenage years for me i was
a strange mix of um
i knew i had talent so like you know
surf wise it was kind of a place for me
to
show that but at the same time with
people or with media that kind of thing
i was really kind of shy
to the point where i didn't like to take
pictures in front of people because it
embarrassed me and that kind of thing
you know i didn't like signing
autographs and because i
i just felt silly i actually remember my
first autograph when i was 10 years old
how'd that go my mom worked at this uh
this little cafe on the beach that we
grew up
surfing in front of called the islander
hut and uh the owner's wife
i won this contest the east coast
championships and when i got home she
was like oh my gosh you're going to be a
famous surfer one day you're going to be
a professional or whatever she's like
you won this big competition you need to
sign something for me
and i was so embarrassed took me like a
half an hour to sign this piece of paper
i didn't know what to do i didn't
i didn't know how to sign an autograph
and like i remember like 15 20 minutes
later she's like you got that autograph
for me yet and i was like i don't even
know what that means you know
um you know fast forwarding to you know
the context of
taking i don't know there's a book i
read as a kid that was adult children of
alcoholics or something like that
and and uh i read that probably when i
was like my early 20s
and i was experiencing a lot of um i was
going through a breakup
and as you do you get really emotional
during breakups and experiencing
a lot of things you you want to you want
to
evolve you want to learn and and grow
quickly in those situations so you can
maybe save the relationship
or you know not blow it by making stupid
mistakes it should be
natural to get right so
you know at that age i started
identifying like oh there's some weird
stuff going down in my family there's
some really
unhealthy dynamics around money and
around um communication all those sort
of things
and as i got older
because i did really well you know i
obviously
started winning world titles and making
money and
you know in some ways a lot of the
family
pressure or focus was around me
and i i think if someone stands out as
doing something
extraordinary in a family that's kind of
natural so my
my god son he's 13 i have two god sons
and and one of them's 13 and
he's a really good surfer and his dad's
one of my oldest best friends and
i heard him saying the other day on an
interview he said uh
you know the thing about when you have a
kid he has two kids and
he said something about when you have a
kid who's doing really well or something
it takes so much time up
for the rest of the family and so much
of the focus of the family might be
around that one person as opposed to
equally amongst everybody and it made me
just in this past week since i heard
that has made me think about that a lot
because i have an older brother sean and
i think
as we got into teenagers that was
probably kind of funny for him that you
know i started doing so well and
he didn't keep on that same trajectory
as when we were kids
you know i think it was tough for him i
know it was tough for him he recently
said
something to me to the effect that he
wished he wasn't a pro surfer you know
he wished
he had done something else at that time
which was really sad for me to hear you
know because
we grew up just loving surfing so much
and it created a life for us it created
all our travel and friendships and
and all these memories on the around the
world work and you know it was it just
became everything
and uh as as a lot of the pressure i
think
was on me you know i bought a house when
i was 17
and i was paying for a lot of things you
know for everybody
and that kind of thing so it there's a
certain control that happens for
someone in that position and
it needs to be handled with care and
it needs you know might need some help
and we didn't have that help or
understanding and and so all of us i
think suffered through that time
so you know in 2003 if we're going to
fast forward to then
um when my friend said that to me my
friend trevor he said
maybe you're the one who needs to sort
of
handle this because you're aware of it
you know all the problems that are going
on their family and
you know there's there's things you can
see about your mom's struggle that you
could help and your brother
and blah blah things with your daughter
and i really kind of resented that
because
in some ways i took on a fatherly role
in my family but i was the middle child
right and um i think i kind of longed to
be put back in that place of like
i'm the middle child i'm not the oldest
you're my mom
you're my older brother you're my dad
i'm pr i'm probably getting ahead of
myself here because i
you know some of these conversations
haven't fully been aired out but
you know there's just a dynamic that
happens and i'm i'm not placing blame on
anyone for those but um you know just
trying to kind of
objectively look and understand because
i'm still growing through this stuff and
you know wanting to understand it from
from all perspectives i
i did become like a mediator in my
family you know i was scared for my
parents to break up as a kid and
i just imagined in my head i think i
lived in this dreamland where everyone
got along and
it was a movie and it was a happy ending
and um
you know that's not always the case you
know the happy ending comes when all the
lessons are learned
usually so when i was confronted with
the fact that i might need to be the
person to kind of
help mend a lot of these issues in the
family i i resented that because i was
longing for someone else to do it and i
wouldn't have to do the work
and i wouldn't have to come up with
those answers and
it's easier if it's not you
why did why did trevor say that to you
what was it about that
point in time or the the surrounding
conversation or background that led him
to say that to you
well because trevor you know he was one
of my best friends or
you know still is on a deep level but we
just don't spend a lot of time together
these days
we've been kind of off in different
directions but trevor was like a six
time
iron man champion in australia and uh
he'd been through a lot of the sort of
emotional and
and uh financial and stardom if you will
pitfalls that can happen
you know he on his own level he had had
a lot of that stuff
happen to him and he was able to get
through it
you know he he had you know and i i
wouldn't say anything that he hasn't
stated publicly or whatever but
you know he he went through divorce and
uh money problems and all sorts of
things and
he was able to eventually work it out
and he got married again
his current wife and his ex-wife are
best of friends all the kids get along
like
he really has a happy healthy situation
coming out of some some things that were
not so pretty at the time
i think he saw that with me you know he
just he saw that i was learning quickly
we were doing these courses together and
he was helping me a lot and
i was able to talk about things that i
couldn't talk about with anyone else
before in my life and
so i think it wasn't so much a challenge
to me as it was
hey i see something special here that
can make you feel good and
i think you can fix these things up and
it'll make every other aspect your life
better and
more coherent and and uh happy
so it's kind of one of those things what
what type of
courses were they were there any
particular things that you
found helpful or that stuck with you
they were
well they were sort of like personal
exercise
courses maybe metaphysical if you will
um
i don't know just where you you spend a
lot of time with other people and
do these processes of being the listener
or being the person who has problems or
overseeing
those things and doing these little
exercises and then just talking about
your feelings just like simple stuff
like really simple stuff in the course
they kind of ask you to not really
talk about it too much outside of it but
we would just do these
exercises and then afterwards you talk
about how you feel and you relate those
feelings to the rest your life and the
way that you as a person
approach and experience life so you just
kind of look at all your filters
and it's just an experiential kind of
exercise
and i started realizing that even in the
simplest things that you do every day
the way you wake up
and think about them and approach them
is how you approach life and
so everything's kind of a metaphor of
another thing yeah
the sort of filters and stories that we
might not even be
aware of you mentioned metaphysics and
we don't have to get super metaphysical
here but i think metaphor
and we'll just get quantum physical
we'll just get quantum physical here for
for 20 minutes hold on to your panties
everybody uh
there were two books that that you
mentioned in in tribal mentors i'd be
curious
uh to know when either or both of them
came into your life
just in terms of influence and sort of
shaping your thinking
the first is actually the second one you
mentioned but the prophet
by khalil gibran which i also have
that's a beautiful little book
it's a great book yeah and why don't we
start there and then we'll get to the
second one but
how did that enter your life god that's
so weird
he just brought that up one of my best
friends is named khalil
and i met him about i don't know eight
years ago
seven or eight years ago and he's just
become such a
big part of my life and uh he's an ex
drug addict who was nearly dead and
homeless and
penniless and got himself together now
he's
more or less a health food addict and uh
owns a bunch of smoothie
stores in l.a called sun life organics
he's just really
like this guy's a success story in his
life you know but
the book and i'd never known a khalil
before but i just
flashed on that because my mom gave me
that book the prophet
and i think i want to say i was in my
early 20s
maybe late teens to early 20s and she
gave me this book and i don't know how
she knew about it it was
i don't know i it just seemed like an
extraordinary book to me it became
like my bible because i felt like i
could read a little piece of it it would
hold me over for a month you know maybe
one or two pages
totally yeah you might just open to some
aspect of life that you're questioning
or whatever and
you read you know they say all the great
things are simple things
and you that book really kind of
is a cliff notes to life in an in simple
way
but i just felt it really it was a
really inspiring book
um and it didn't take a lot of effort to
get
something from it yeah it's a very uh
this book found me in a very
uh tumultuous period of my life and i
ended up reading
like you mentioned one or two very short
chapters two pages perhaps
each day and it it had the effect of
taking what could seem like an
overwhelmingly complex world and
distilling it down to something simple
that you could
reflect on and use for the next few days
the second book i'll bring it up is one
with a longer title
and that is the tao of health sex and
longevity by daniel
reed reid could you speak to this book
and same idea how it came into your life
and what you take from it what are some
of the takeaways
or impacts in your life yeah um
i started reading that book in the early
2000s
maybe 2345 somewhere in there
[Music]
and i i just found a lot of the well
if i were to rewind a little bit in the
late 90s
i started to learn a lot about the
gracies
um jujitsu i didn't start practicing but
i was reading a lot about them and
reading about hixon who i later became
friends with and
they talk about a diet a food combining
diet where you don't mix proteins and
carbs together in meals
and you don't mix fruits with either and
you could have greens with
sort of anything um that's essentially
what food combining is i i had read a
book in the
mid 19 around 96 or 97 called fit for
life which was kind of the same thing
and i think i'd been inspired by the
gracies to read that and then
i don't remember who gave me the dial of
health sex and longevity but i started
reading that and got really really
into the the diet aspect of it getting
into the food combining thing
and started following it kind of
religiously i think i read it in 98
originally and i kept i i sort of kept
it with me for about 10 years
is what it was and in 98 i was traveling
with shane dorian
that's whose son is my god son and shane
and i were traveling around the tour
together that year and
i became kind of like our the chef for
both of us he just told me just tell me
what to eat because he knew i was super
into diet
and so we got really into our diets and
um i felt like he was
helping me be a guinea pig to see if
this thing worked and
i found myself sleeping like six hours a
night and feeling like i was totally
rested
my body just felt much more relaxed and
energetic
and um you know there's other things in
the book that were helpful too
there's a lot of breathing techniques
that i try to incorporate
myself didn't really do them practicing
with anyone else
and it gets into all sorts of things
around you know
obviously it's the title of sexuality
too um
so it dives into all that kind of thing
too but like they just
using everything in your life in a
healthy way and um
i don't know it's one of those books i
just i had to travel with it for years
i just would always keep it it was like
just in case i need to read something
i'll have it with me you know it was
always in the bottom of my bag for a
long time and
i probably recommended that book
literally at this point to tens of
thousands of people
maybe hundreds of thousands or millions
even after this it'll be millions for
sure
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by dry
farm wines i'm a wine drinker i love it
love a few glasses over meals with
friends that said i hate
hangovers it kills me often for multiple
days right now all of the wine in my
house
is from dry farm wines also for my last
two book launch parties
all the wine has been from dry farm
wines why is that
because in my personal experience their
wine means more fun with fewer
headaches dry farm wines only ships wine
that meet very stringent criteria
close to sugar free so less than 0.15
grams per glass
lower alcohol less than 12.5 alcohol
additive free
there are more than 70 fda approved wine
making additives
the fewer the better in your wine lower
sulfites organic and produced by small
family farms all dry farm wines are
laboratory tested for purity standards
by certified independent enologists
and all of their wines are backed by a
100 happiness promise they will either
replace or refund any wine you don't
love
last but not least i find delicious
wines i never would have found otherwise
so it's a lot of fun
saves me time and research and i have
fewer headaches other fans of dry farm
wines include the incredible doctor dom
d'agostino who's been on this podcast
very popular guest you remember the guy
who did a 10 day fast and then
did 10 repetitions of deadlifts with 500
pounds that guy he drinks their wine
even when on a ketogenic
diet which can work dry farm wines is
offering you an extra bottle in your
first box for a penny because it's
alcohol it can't be free
find all the details and collect your
wine at dryfarmwines.com
tim check it out dry farm wines dot com
slash tim
and one more time i love this stuff
dryfarmwines.com
tim
you mentioned a name that i'd love to
come back to and that's hix and gracie
so i know
quite a lot about hixon i've only met
him in person once very briefly so that
he wouldn't
i don't think he would remember me but
he has now that i think about it
an incredible physical practice that in
some ways if i had to guess
share some similarities with your
physical practice
i remember long ago watching a
documentary
largely about hixing called choke which
was about i believe his initial
competition
in pride the early early iterations of
pride
and watching his yogic practices his
abdominal work
his breathing cold exposure etc
how would you say the two of you are
most similar
or different what similarities and
differences do you see
it's so funny because remember uh years
ago everyone was doing that ice bucket
challenge you pour some cold water on
your head and that's like a big thing
right and yeah i remember back watching
choke
and that was before i knew hixon and
watching him
go into like basically a ice cold
temperature water in
in japan and training for these fights
just getting his mind
strong and you know physically mentally
emotionally
totally prepared for war and his
breathing techniques are just
like out of this world you know like wim
hoff's the
the guy who's famous for his breathing
stuff but hickson was
doing that you know 25 years ago or more
and you know i had heard that hixon
could move
every muscle in his body independent of
any other muscle
he had such control and like for people
who don't know jujitsu
you know the gracies are learning jiu
jitsu by the time they're two years old
in that family
you know kids wrestle all boys wrestle
but they were
wrestling at a young age tiny kids with
technique and learning the skills
and learning how not to hurt each other
and so it was
as natural as breathing or anything for
them
and um i always had real admiration from
afar for hixon before meeting him and
then
we became friends i i'm not quite sure
the first time i met him
i met him at rincon surfing i think it
was the early 2000s or
late 90s met him one day in the car park
and then
a few years later a couple years later i
got invited over to this house to go do
a private
uh session with him and taught me and my
friend travis and jujitsu
and then i kind of think he gave me a
few uh one-on-one
sessions and i sort of sponsored him for
surfboards and would pay for his
surfboards
and um like an informal kind of
you know you scratch my back i scratch
yours but i always had this huge
admiration for him and i was just really
you know happy to know him and get to
pick his brain sometimes but
in about 2008
it was about 2008 i was i saw i saw him
one day came to the surfboard factory
where i was
who i was sponsored by and grew up in
santa barbara and he goes
he's like you know man i think you
should stop now i think you should
i think you should quit and i said why
and he goes you know you're gonna give
all these young guys
a chance to beat you and you you're not
gonna be as sharp you're to you're going
to lose
your desire you're going to get it
complacent you know
and then guys who shouldn't beat you are
going to beat you and when you look back
you're going to be upset about it
and about three years later i saw him
and i had won
two or three more world titles in that
time and i said you know
if i listen to you i wouldn't have this
many you know if i listen to you i would
only have eight
and now i got 11. you know and he's like
oh man you're right you're right
and uh there is always that question for
athletes like when do you stop and
and what's the right time and you go out
at the peak
or shortly after it and you know
it's a weird thing because it depends on
your purpose you know it depends on
what message you're sending and that
message can change too
and and i feel like mine has but that
message that doesn't have to be so
centered around your ego
it can be an evolution and um people who
say like guys people need to go out on
top why
so i mean yeah that's great too but
obviously
if you're at the top of your game you're
still you're still beating people you're
still beating everyone
and um passing the torch sometimes
you know somebody's got to take you out
and
uh you know that can be a respectable
and respectful way too
and uh i've always kind of welcomed that
uh in my later years
here on tour i've sort of welcomed like
i i want to see the level
be what my mind imagined when i was 15
20 years old
not somewhere behind me you know i
wanted to just keep going and
and i want to be part of that evolution
to push that
and you know at 48 years old i know
nobody takes me lightly
in a heat when they compete against me
and
you know that's i think that's an honor
in itself
you know that they still you know the
best guys in the world are still
worried when they get in the heat with
me and i'm i'm not
dumb no i know where my level is you
know there's certain times that i'm
i can be the best guy and there's other
times where i got to work on it
or you know or i'm not right there but
if you're enjoying it you love
it and it's your passion and it it
surfing is a different thing you know
kind of like what would i compare it to
strangely enough golf they're both
sports you can do until
you're old you know you can do way up in
late into your life
you're not gonna be doing that with
football and baseball or basketball
so much you know not hardcore anyways
i'm gonna ask you about the evolution
of surfing in a moment but i want to
come back to hixson just
just for another minute and that is what
were what were some of the things you
learned from hixon or that most
impressed you you mentioned
picking his brain about things was there
anything that you picked up from him or
that really astonished you about him you
mentioned that individual muscle control
and i had referenced the abdominal
exercises which kind of makes it sound
like
crunches but what i'm talking about is
what you saw and you probably remember
this in chokers
he's in this freezing cold river snow
everywhere and he's also
moving independently as he breathes his
abdomen where it looks like his guts are
just moving
in every possible direction like an
octopus under his skin it's one of the
strangest things i've ever seen
but yeah what are some of the things
that you picked up from hixon if
anything
or took note of funny enough probably
one of the simplest things
is the first thing that swings to mind
and
that is efficiency because when he
anytime he's given me a jiu jitsu lesson
he's given me a few privates and and he
did the same thing for my little brother
one day with me
and it was all about efficiency of
movement
you know he said look you know i can
fight a guy i'm like 170 or whatever
175.
he's like i can fight a guy who's 250
pounds and i'm stronger than him
not because i have more strength but
because i understand leverage i
understand how the body moves
and the efficiency of trapping someone's
joint
and using leverage instead of just
energy you know instead of just wasting
my energy and
using strength i'm using superior method
and technique
one thing i really have always respected
about hixon is how disciplined he was
especially like seeing that that footage
of him
knowing that the level he got to with
his breathing and his stomach you know
his muscle movements and
his mastery of jiu jitsu and his arts
the amount of time it took to get there
and he obviously had something special
you know he had a certain way to look at
it that no one else did
and that's why he was the greatest so
it's
taking all the best techniques all
aspects you know from diet
to breathing to you know understanding
his body
understanding his opponents and what
they're good and bad at and using
all that it becomes an equation that you
you know when you get to the highest
levels you don't think of the equation
it just
you understand that you know the answer
and um so you and you just trust that
and use it
and so in the simplicity there's a a
mastery
and um i think that's what i've picked
up from
the times i've spent around hixing i
promised i would come back to the
evolution of surfing where do you think
the evolution of surfing might be going
is is there anything that would be
inconceivable for most people today to
imagine that you think
is coming down the pike where do you
think things are going
i've said to a few people in the last
few years last
five or ten years that i would hate to
be a young surfer right now
because the levels you got to go to
whether it's going to be just competing
like just small wave
performance and technique or it's gonna
if you're gonna be a big wave guy like
the stuff guys are doing now is so crazy
that young kids who have any fear of big
waves right now must be just like
having no understanding of what they
could do to get to that level
guys are surfing regularly surfing 60 70
80 foot waves
and um you know you need to do a lot of
preparing for that ahead of time a lot
of
a lot of putting yourself in un safe
not unsafe um unfamiliar territory you
know pool work
underwater work breathing breath holds
you know water safety classes big they
have these classes
called uh big wave rescue
there's an acronym for it b-w-r-a-g
anyways it's all about big waves and
practicing and practicing all the water
safety
so there's these courses you know
they're really good for young guys to go
to actually
they'd be good for it they could
translate to anybody even people who
don't surf you know but
they're they're kind of built
specifically for like being able to
be comfortable in big gnarly situations
and also go save people in the middle of
you know this earth and i'll link to
that in the show notes for folks
yeah all aspects of water safety and
it's really like
a passion played by the surfers who do
it you know everyone's kind of looking
out for each other and
you know i've had a number of friends
drown and not make it and i've had a
number of friends drown and be saved
and a lot of those most of those who
were saved were because all these kind
of techniques that everyone's
been learning from divers and lifeguards
and
all sorts of water safety people in fact
there's one friend of mine
who uh drowned and was saved and then
about i don't know a couple years later
he actually
did cpr and another friend of ours who
drowned and saved him
so there's a there's a real tight
fraternity
community in in the surf world
especially in the big wave world
and you know guys are looking out for
each other because they know it's it's a
life and death thing all the time
and if you if you look at the the
evolution
just size-wise performance-wise
technique-wise
over the last say five to ten years i
mean as it seems to be mirrored in many
other places like mma
there's this almost exponential curve
that seems to be persisting and i'd be
curious to know what you think
things might look like in say five years
time
and and you've been part of course of
innovating with technology right the
kelly slater wave company producing the
longest man-made high-performance open
barrel waves i remember the initial
videos
making the circles and just blowing
people's minds what do you think the
state-of-the-art
training will look like for people who
do
want to hone their skill given how
intimidating it can be
now if they want to compete as an
example what do you think it might look
like five years from now
i kind of wonder um you know i think
this last five years was really
a fast evolution in wave pool technology
wave tech
man-made wave technologies i think it
might i don't know if it's going to
speed up or slow down right now
i feel like it's going to slow down a
little bit because there's a number of
different technologies and now it's
about
perfecting them just innovating on what
is already there
and then having surfers ride them and
give feedback to
what else they would like to see but
there's quite a lot of good waves being
made by
machines at this time there's i want to
say three
distinct different technologies with
different kinds of waves five years from
now
i just expect there will be more of
these made you know there's probably
six or eight around the world that have
become sort of destinations for people
to go ride
there's one in abu dhabi or dubai
there's
there was two in texas now there's one
but i think the other one's going to be
rebuilt there's one going in
at least one going into florida if not
two um there's
one in england there's one in us down in
melbourne australia and i think another
being built on the gold coast right now
and then potentially we're building one
on the sunshine coast as well
so five years from now i don't think
there's going to be a time where
surfers are
completely stumped for waves you're
always going to have somewhere within
your access you can go get a wave on any
given day the waveforms that they have
in australia right now is down in
melbourne
and i was talking to a friend recently
he goes oh yeah
like a bunch of my buddies have gotten a
flight from byron bay
flown all the way to melbourne in the
morning surf two sessions at the pool
and get home by dark
or get home like just for a late dinner
and that's a two-hour flight each way
and he said they're happy to do it again
next month or in two months or whatever
so these things are becoming you know
destinations for people and
it's it's just like a supplement to your
surfing just like a
vitamins would be to your diet it's just
another way to get
get your fix of uh getting in the water
and getting something done but
now you see people advancing evolving
they're surfing a lot quicker and
that's going to be the case that's going
to be the thing like
my god son jackson i'll probably just
keep talking about him but he's 13 and
he's one of the best aerialists of his
age in the world if not the best
at his age in the world right now and
he's really only been surfing about four
years
and you know i've grown men all the time
just going oh my god how's jackson he's
unbelievable
you know people watch his edits and see
the things he's doing but he's spent a
lot of time in the in these different
ways pools already
practicing the errors over and over
again and shane was saying how
he's like man the first time we went it
was crazy to see jackson's evolution
over the course of like two days or
three days and
how much better he got in that amount of
time because
there's a real crossover now between
skate and surf so
you see all the guys who are really good
at airs i would say
90 of them anyways are good skaters and
um
so they understand the rotations and the
grabs and that kind of thing and
when we were kids we didn't really have
access to skate parks and ramps and
stuff
and now there's a skate park in every
city almost all these guys have
a bunch of friends who are great skaters
or pro skaters or even someone in their
family you know
it's a great skater so there's a real
solid cross over there
it's just more access more time on the
mat you know
yeah it also seems like with the wave
pools at least i recall
a friend of mine joking that surfing
he's very good surfers he said surfing
should really be called paddling because
you're spending a lot of your time
paddling and it would just seem that
with a wave pool i i
feel free to chime in but he said with a
wave pole it seems like you get a
density of
repetitions of surfing that
is is difficult or impossible to
replicate
elsewhere just in terms of number of
reps per hour
in that sense i heard you made a sound
how would you
respond to that no totally i mean
because in the ocean you might search
all my years i've thought about certain
waves that
look good for a certain maneuver and i
might go and surf that wave once every
few years
and it might have that section i'm
looking for only
once every couple times i go there and i
might
get that wave you know even less
frequent than that
so the point is that the sections we
need with the right speed and size and
all that thing to do certain maneuvers
is so rare to find in the ocean
and now we can start to design those
into man-made waves
so that if you ever have that situation
in the ocean it's not unfamiliar
it's you can master that before you ever
take it to the ocean so then you go out
in the ocean you go into competition or
whatever and you've got something in
your
in your back pocket and then nobody else
has or that you're not
unfamiliar with if you were say
20 years old and had the level
of surfing that you had when you were 20
what if that were today
what advice might you give yourself
about the learning process
it doesn't have to relate to technology
but is there any advice you would give
your
20 year old self about honing the craft
improving the learning process gosh i
mean i would probably just say go skate
a lot
okay just get on a skate go get on a
skateboard because you can go carve and
you can do errors and
those are the two things you need in
surfing you need to you need to really
understand
and differentiate the two you know
you're either in surfing your
most guys are either a power surfer or
an air you know
maneuver trick surfer and um it's almost
rare to see somebody who's really great
at both
um we're starting to get more and more
there's like you drawn john florence and
there's
um gabriel medina and there's jordy
smith and there's quite a few guys now
but
when i was on tour and when i got on
tour when i got on tour i'd say there's
nobody
and as i was on tour there were very few
over the years that were
good at all those different aspects i
mean my mind almost draws a blank until
just this modern era now who have been
able to understand
there's a real difference in the
approach of doing those maneuvers the
base of power surfing
where you're just carving up and the air
stuff where
you kind of have to be more horizontal
and lateral and stay over your board
unless you're doing grabs and then you
know when you start doing grabs and
rotations and
inverting stuff then it's the everything
goes to a little different level and you
you have to be
schooled in some other skill set
you know like skating or gym you know
gym work if you
if you were to go work with a gymnast
specifically with a gymnast who
understands flips and rotate and
spinning and
that kind of stuff and landing back on
your feet if you're really going to dive
into it all you
can't discount your diet you can't
discount bodywork you can't discount
doing yoga or pilates and staying supple
getting some extra strength and bone
density but
not getting too big from using weights
so there's always this kind of balance
for surfing you don't want to be a
giant strong dude but you don't want to
be a little
weakling either you just kind of need
this nice balance and blend between all
those
things you mentioned bodywork this seems
to be an important component
of i suppose just physical practice for
you or
regeneration there are million and one
different types of bodywork
how do you use bodywork what are the
types that you
have ended up focusing on for yourself
if any i've gone through
most everyone you can imagine from
shiatsu to
thai massage swedish deep tissue
biosync
i mean all sorts of different you know
i've tried everything all the
chiropractics and
osteopaths and all that kind of stuff
but in general i do need a little bit of
adjusting
some chiropractics because i have
scoliosis
i have a pretty big curve in my back and
from that my muscles get really
imbalanced
so i kind of need a blend i mean my neck
will go out and my lower back will go
out so i need to get adjusted
kind of put that back i sometimes throw
a rib out that sounds painful
yeah it's a little it's different than
breaking rape it's just more annoying
you can still kind of surf through it
with adrenaline but it
is annoying the way i usually do it it
kind of pinches something in my neck so
i can't turn to the left
i feel like zoolander um
i can't turn left
[Laughter]
i really like thai massage because it's
deep
it's almost like lazy man's yoga you
know in a way
yeah um you know i've been disciplined
for many years i've been i've spent over
30 years being
pretty disciplined with my body and what
i put into it and
and um you know all that kind of stuff
and
but i uh in doing that i'm never too
obsessive about
any one thing i'll go through like binge
periods where i'm really obsessive about
my diet but
i don't love to work out so i i like to
kind of
consistently get some body work i like
to surf enough
because surfing's fun you know i just
love to surf so
it keeps me fit and if i surf enough i'm
at a level that's pretty good for my
cardio
and for my strengths but i generally
always
need a little bit of extras you know i
should spend more time stretching
especially my
hips and my hamstrings if you can
picture a surfer paddling we got our
arc our back arched the whole time so i
can actually bend backwards amazing i
can put my feet on my head and that kind
of thing
but bending forward i'm stiffer because
i spent my whole life with my shoulders
back and my
back arched you know blend for me is
just if i feel like
something's out if my back goes out or
something like i got to get adjusted
let it relax get some
anti-inflammatories once in a while
because
the stress around contest if your body's
out of whack is
annoying too and then um yeah just get
to get that body work get those muscles
worked out that are
imbalanced you know if you're a little
too tight there a little too weak there
the ones that are built up too much you
got to kind of like stretch out
and just for folks who don't know thai
massage i'll do my best to do a quick
description and then please add anything
that we're missing but you described it
as lazy man's yoga
it's a a lot of it is done on a mat
people will often
stretch you i've this is the one form of
massage i've explored quite a bit
and use pressure right the feet
lots of yeah it might use blood
lots of water walking on you and also
traction i mean depending on the style
so it's a it's a really comprehensive
system
uh i've i've also found time massage
extremely
helpful how often do you get how often
do you have bodywork done
well i'd like to get something done
every week but you know sometimes i'll
get it a couple times a week
if i'm in one place and i got somebody i
like to work with
i'll go two or three times in a week
sometimes and then i might not go for a
month once in a while if i'm competing
though i like to try to get something at
least once a week once a week
and but if i'm at the contest sorry to
jump in there
if i'm at a contest we usually have
massage therapists there so
each day i'll get a little bit of
something during contest days just a few
more questions kelly i know it's uh
it's late what time is it over there at
the moment it's got to be on the late
side
oh i don't know 1 30.
oh my god 1 30 a.m hey we're partying
man
we're partying and uh yeah this is
another surprise
in the kelly story is your history as a
night owl which is pretty astonishing
at least was unexpected for me but just
a few more questions for you this is one
on behalf of a friend of mine who is
if you haven't ever met him i'd i'd
actually love for you guys to meet at
some point but his name is josh waitskin
i don't think he'd mind being named
he was the basis for searching for bobby
fischer so he was considered a chess
prodigy as a kid he hates that word
prodigy but
nonetheless um very uh very very
successful chess player
and then uh was a world champion in tai
chi push hands the first black belt
under marcelo garcia who's sort of the
michael jordan
of grappling and he's one of my all-time
favorites
yeah yeah so josh co-founded a school
with him in new york
and now he is spending his time on the
water and this is his new passion
and uh he's fascinated by all water
sports
and i'd love to and this is uh this is a
question that he posed
ask you about foiling what is your
opinion of foiling
or e-foiling as a supplement
or adjunct to surfing or otherwise
that's my add-on but really what he was
wondering is does it connect or not
connect to surfing
in your mind well the best guys in the
world are surfers so
yeah it connects when i was a little kid
there used to be this sort of slogan
cocoa beach the small wave world
in a small wave capital of the world for
whatever reason there was like you know
big emphasis of surfing in cocoa beach
and it was probably a slogan from rajon
surf shop or something but
somehow it became known as like a small
wave capital
and then in the last 20
30 years cocoa beach is not on the
surfing radar at all no one comes to
cocoa beach to go
surfing from anywhere else in the world
they do from like
orlando and they might from down south
florida but they don't it's not like a
destination for people from other places
in the world you're gonna go to
hawaii or indo or tahiti or
france for that matter portugal um
but with the foiling thing so you know
for people who don't know foiling just
google it you can go on youtube it's
like a surfboard on a
hydrofoil so you don't have the
resistance of the board on the water
yeah you're riding under the water and
you're riding like it's it's
it's probably the closest thing you can
imagine to flying but being in the water
just think of all the america's cup
boats now the ones that lift off
or those fairies the super high speed
fairies that ride in a foil and all the
energy
all the weight lifts up off the water so
there's just so little resistance and
the bigger the foil the more the more
lift you have so the faster you're going
the less
foil size you need i can't really speak
to it because i'm a complete kook and
novice i've done it like three times
i've done the e-foil once
and i think the a4 is a little goofy i'm
just gonna throw it out there
i think it's really good for learning
it's kind of training wheels for
for foiling in my eyes um
you do it to kind of get the feel of
being lifting up off the water and not
having
not relying on your board edges and
stuff to create
the turns and it's foiling is a little
counter-intuitive when we surf
when you lean into a rail into a turn
you're pushing all your energy and
weight down
into that rail and you're getting a lift
back from that rail
when you foil when you push on one side
wherever you put your force
it lifts back against you in a way that
kind of throws the board the opposite
way you think it might
so if i if i'm surfing and i lean my
right rail down in the water
that rail goes down of course i'm
getting a push back against it but
in foiling when you lean to the right if
you put if you lean to the right and
then put your
energy down to the right the foil kicks
the board back up against you and you
kind of
fold in half so when you when you lean
right you almost got to put
equal amount of pressure on the left at
the same time it's hard to
try to explain because i am such a
novice so there's a little bit of
counter-intuitive it's almost like
if you're riding a bike and you're
turning right
you have to turn the steering wheel left
a little bit to go right it's it's the
weirdest
sensation but it's so cool looking
like the amount of speed you can get and
what i'm saying about florida being like
cocoa beach being the smallest capital
of the world i'm
i'm just starting to think that florida
might be a good destination again for
people
that want to go foiling because we have
these really shallow offshore
shoals off of um cape canaveral uh
basically
where nasa space center is and um my
friends have been getting like mile long
rides out there
you can just catch these open ocean
swells and they don't break and you just
you can go so fast back and forth on the
things and it's so cool looking it's
completely silent
and there's just no wake and
i don't know it looks like nothing else
in the world i kind of want to get into
it but
i'm scared once i do it's going to mess
my surfing up so i'm kind of
kind of waiting i was i was telling you
i was working out with tom carroll the
other day and
tom foils almost every morning and he
says as soon as i'm done falling i got
to get back on a surfboard so i don't
forget
that feeling or else my surfing goes
downhill
it is it is a a beautiful and eerie
visual to see foiling if people haven't
seen it we'll put some links in the show
notes but
uh it's very it's unlike
anything you've ever seen particularly
if you're not familiar with with water
sports at all it just looks it's kind of
hard
at first within the first few seconds to
even compute what is happening
because like you said there's a yeah
somebody can be on a tiniest little wave
and they're going 20 miles an hour
yeah it's you know or whatever just
flying it's really wild
just a few more questions then a little
break here
uh are there any any really great
moments in the water that
come to mind that were not captured on
camera any
obviously there's all of the practice
and lots of sessions on the water but
does anything come to mind not that you
regret that it wasn't captured on camera
but
like a standout moment for you that uh
has has just been kind of locked in the
amber of your memory i went on a trip
down to central america one time there's
this really great wave that was
happening years ago funny enough
strangely enough it got ruined
by the 2011 tsunami which wasn't huge
when it hit there but it was really
powerful and small and it
changed this break in particular that we
were surfing
um but we went down there and i i
brought my friend to shoot
like 1000 frames a second on a phantom
camera like the best footage you could
ever get at the time
and we shot the best day i've ever seen
at this place
like a day you get very few times in
your life like maybe the best day surf i
ever had
and he filmed the whole thing and we
flew from there
to to haiti and we got to tahiti and i
said hey
um let me know when i can see that
footage and like the next day i called
him and i said
have you looked at it yet he's like um
there might be a problem with it or
something but i'll let you know later
i'm like what do you mean he's like i
don't know i just like
trying to go through the hard drives and
stuff so i go down i go and see him the
next day
and i said oh yeah what's going on and
he goes there's no footage i go what do
you mean there's no footage like you
miss some waves or like
he goes no there's there's no footage at
all and i was like what do you mean
and he goes there's just there's no
footage like he goes i think when we
were going out on the jet ski something
came loose from the hard drive to the
camera and it just never even got one
frame of footage
so we we don't have any footage at all
of that whole
day i was equally like upset and
thought it was funny and i actually in a
way
i kind of i'm kind of glad that it
didn't happen because
this was this place was so magical and
um
i felt cheap filming it and showing it
to the world
and uh and and it's renowned for people
like dropping their cameras that have
filmed good sessions like there's like
kind of this mystique around this place
and like a whole bunch of people my
friends that have been down there filmed
and stuff
like my friends that live down there and
and they've dropped cameras in the water
after a whole day of filming and like
somehow somebody erased the footage like
all these things have happened so
like the footage of this place has never
really gotten out and
and um and then the site then the
tsunami hit and ruined the sandbar
that had built up for you know who knows
how long decades
and um so it's kind of funny it sort of
hit itself and and uh although i wanted
to see that footage
we didn't have it yeah the bermuda
triangle and then the beach was like
enough of these people with their
cameras let's change the landscape
it happened yeah that's amazing uh
kelly last question what are you most
looking forward to
in terms of of goals for yourself
doesn't have to be related to surfing
but really it could be of course a
over the next handful of years like this
obviously this period of time with the
covet thing
has been a i hope it's been a time of
reflection for everybody
i think it's a time for all of us to sit
back and think about our health
think about what's important put some
money away
you know i think about all the people
who lost their jobs and who live on
credit and
who don't save for a rainy day and you
know people are in far worse situations
than that that don't have a
roof over their head i think it's it's
one of those times to really think about
kind of everything that's important in
your life and strangely enough if you
look at my youtube feed
i would say half of the stuff that i
watch is converting vans to a home
and i have this sort of after all these
years of like
wanting to you know make money from when
i was a kid so i could buy a house to
then
buying homes in different parts of the
world and now i'm
sort of looking forward to either living
on a boat one day or living in a van
that i can just live anywhere
and uh making it kind of simple the only
problem is i have too many surfboards
and
too many golf clubs but um
you could have you could have a caravan
you could have the first van be the home
and then
well and you know too many countries i'd
like to be in so
but um yeah i i think just um
taking some time after being on this
whirlwind for
30 plus years i mean nearly
nearly 30 years on tour but you know
another
10 years on top of that chasing waves
from when i was a young kid
to just scaling it back to you know
who i like to surf with and where
what else i want to include in my life
or take out of it
just looking forward to enjoying the
next 40 years of life
and and um 50 years 80 years i don't
know how long can we live at that point
but tbd yeah looking looking forward to
that and you know more
more i think more personal uh growth
uh the surfing has become real crowded
and
you almost have to become spiritual to
enjoy it sometimes because there's so
many people in the water
um so you know learning to to enjoy and
enjoy what i have and to be able to
share it you know a kid
that i surfed with yesterday wrote me a
message today online and
he said hey you know i really want to
like be a pro surfer
i really want to get as good as i can
and try to be a pro and make a career
and he's like any advice
and he's like sorry for bugging you and
i was like no
like it's it's sort of it's probably
strange how much i
i enjoy sharing
all this stuff that i've learned with
younger guys if they want to ask me you
know i think maybe sometimes people are
intimidated to ask me or
don't think i'll want to talk about it
or something but
i'm really happy to kind of share any of
those things i can with
younger surfers who are hungry for it
and
i thought it was cool that he kind of
had the balls to just say hey can you
help me out here and
so i gave him a nice long run down do
all these things
go all these places like don't fake it
put your heart into it and give it your
best try and if it works out
great but you know there's a long road i
had to get to that point
you know i don't totally know how good
the kid this particular kid is
i saw a couple clips of them and you
know
in all honesty there's some work to do
there but you know somebody who has
the desire and and is willing to say hey
this is what i want to do
all the best to those people you know
it sounds like somebody like that's
willing to to work and to be humble and
when you're humble
you're teachable you know you're you're
able to learn
it's like you know even someone in my
position who's
you know i've won a lot of contests and
all that stuff and i i still
a lot of times i need to just sit back
and be willing to learn and be humble
and not think i know something and
or know it better than somebody and a
lot of times just
they say teaching is the best way to
learn because you know
going back to that theme we started with
early on with that
2003 when i lost that world title when
you when you teach you mess up
you know and and you learn something
from that and uh you learn
better and better how to understand and
comprehend something and be able to
share it
with somebody not from a place of
righteousness but a place of like you
lived it yeah well we'll try to track
down that
that the comment and the where to go and
what to do to put in the show notes but
uh kelly this is uh this has been great
i look forward to watching the next 50
60 80 150 years depending on
where yeah we're where medic medicine
takes us
and really appreciate you taking the
time i i know
that you have lots of demands on your
time so i appreciate you carving out a
bit of it
for this conversation thanks for tuning
in everybody and
you can find show notes links to
everything at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast
and until next time don't be righteous
be open-minded
if you think you really understand
something try to go teach it to somebody
who's an up-and-comer hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what
on earth is element it is a delicious
sugar-free electrolyte drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw a copic coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb
or paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise mountain biking
etc
another application if you've ever
struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough
and it relates to a bunch of stuff like
a hormone called aldosterone blah blah
when insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick ass
no sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units
fbi sniper teams at least five nfl teams
who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting
and on and on you can try it risk free
if you don't like it element will give
you your money back no questions asked
they have extremely low
return rates so again element lmnt came
up with a very special offer
for you guys they've created tim's club
just go to drinkelement.comtim
select subscribe and save and use promo
code tim's club
to get the 30 count box of element for
only 36
this will be valid for the lifetime of
the subscription and you can pause at
any time
so again check it out it's drink
lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer using promo
code tim's club one more time
drink lmnt element so drink
lmnt.com tim and promo code tim's club
check it out
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for youtube helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h e l i x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim
you